with unique mirrors creating the  illusion of infinite books this chinese  library and bookstore is every story  lovers dream come true while this may  look like an ordinary shop from the  outside inside readers are invited to  settle in for an otherworldly  storytelling adventure the black mirror  floor is one of two distinct design  elements the mirrors create the illusion  of a mirage meant to symbolize water  which has a long-held significance in  yong-jo culture in the past famous  authors and poets gathered by the canals  in this Chinese town secondly the arched  ceiling linked throughout the library  which represent the connection between  people and books Jones chuga cherishes  Jung [ __ ] history while embracing the  future head-on by creating a fate for  the next generation of readers to thrive  the soft lighting and flowing shapes set  a mood meant to entice the literary  curious to settle in for a storytelling  adventure  [Music]